et
[Musique]
les jb vieillissez bout fils les shadoks
de la lune et c'est de se développer le
cerveau mais d'abord voyons quelle est
la solution de notre dernier problème de
mathématiques shadoks
elles ont reçu de nos fidèles
téléspectateurs et charmante
téléspectatrices quantité de réponses
qui malheureusement sont toutes fausses
de sorte que personne n'a gagné le
voyage sur la lune que d'ailleurs nous
ne vous avions pas promis le problème
posé était le suivant si un shadow que
partout j'adore mais à l'heure combien
mettra-t-il de temps pour parcourir 11
qu'un dock m eh bien il naîtra un temps
infini
les onze shadoks m il ne l'est pas
recours à jamais parce que le chat d'oc
que vous a montré malheureusement au
bout de dix shadoks m et ombres
complètement épuisé mais revenons à
notre histoire mais on appétit par les
délicieuses enseignants du professeur
djoko les shadoks de la lune ce livre
est maintenant et sont désemparés à une
véritable hongrie de culture alors à
sortir leur dette
petit à petit ce 8 à 11
bon donc le rester maigrissez may cry
sarah des shadoks mutai eh oui id t il
muté dans des six bien que leur corps
finit par disparaître complètement
pendant que la tête de son côté se
garnissent est de pâtes a pas on avait
un chat d'oc
rien qu'en tête qui ressemblait un
shadok ordinaire peut-être mais qui
était garanti 100% culture éducation la
lune enfin allez partir avec à son bord
la fine fleur de la civilisation caddoc
qui allait répondre à travers l'espace
les bienfaits de la shadoks culture
c'est pas beau ça
assis alors que c'était beau
et encore une fois ce fut le départ les
shadoks à grosse tête sont priés de se
mettre en selle les responsables quant à
eux prendrait place dans le cosmos au
but c'est de loin superviserait les
opéras trois nés les odieux que pas du
tout il n'avait pas poursuivi de luxe et
qu est à telle ou encore pour en arriver
là et que c'était tu allé superviser le
brouillard
décidément commençait de la salle
[Musique]